[Musica]
ciao migliori vini di benvenuto sono i
test
questo è un video un po particolare
perché un video interattivo dovrai
scegliere tu quello che io andrò a fare
l'obiettivo è trovare tutti ingredienti
slime per fare lo slime però ci sono
anche dei nemici nascosti in casa quindi
dovrei riuscire a fare le scelte giuste
come funziona fronte il video ci saranno
delle scelte da fare infatti appariranno
2 caselline una destra e una sinistra o
questa è la tua destra e questa è la via
a sinistra
vabbè comunque dovrei scegliere una
delle caselline ad esempio entra in
quella stanza o messi fuori di casa
una volta scelta quella casellina dovrai
cliccarci sopra
una volta che hai cliccato sopra la
storia continuerà in base alla tua
scelta che potrebbe essere una scelta
giusta o una scelta sbagliata
dovrei continuare andare avanti finché
non vinci il gioco o finché non perdi il
gioco che perdi apparirà una casellina
per ricominciare il gioco da capo così
avrai un altro tentativo insomma una
volta terminato il gioco se riesce a
vincere
potrei tornare su questo video
principale e scrivere nei commenti
quanti tentativi ti ci sono voluti per
vincere il gioco c'è solo una regola lo
spoiler nei commenti potete scrivere
tutte le cose divertenti che volete nei
commenti ad esempio o no sono morto
subito al primo tentativo ma non
scrivete spoiler quindi non scrivete
devi prendere quella decisione
devi cliccare su quella casellina
altrimenti che gusto c'è tra gli altri
giocatori quindi se tutto chiara un
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn e
iniziamo subito il nostro gioco dove
potrei cercare gli ingredienti slime qua
in cameretta oppure esco dalla camera
scegli tu
una delle due opzioni clicca qui
ho qui e continua la storia
[Musica]